hey folks
welcome back to the 91th dark course
live stream podcast q and a yeah i said
91
yeah you did yep i did that's fine i
feel good about it
do you no but it'll do it'll do
you know it conveys the message that's
what language is about
first pass yeah broad brush yeah sure
okay i believe that we forwarded this
question from last week
i am a white male u.s high school
biology teacher in an urban
predominantly black area
crt is encroaching here how can i battle
this to ensure the best education for my
students
right yeah
i mean i think it depends i don't think
we know enough
right i think it depends on what else is
true of the environment
that if um
if the rest of the school if the rest of
the teachers and administrators
are uh into crt
and especially if they are also black uh
it's going to be hard
it's going to be very hard to resist um
if uh
if you have colleagues um
of any color doesn't matter uh who see
this as something to be resisted then i
would i would start there
um rather than you know for with regard
to high school
i don't think you start with the
students i think that's
that's riskier yeah
i also think uh one needs to
play a longer game and recognize that
you are doing anyone a service who
recognizes that there is something amiss
in the arguments used to advance crt
and um that you know planting seeds that
may mature
a year from now or two years from now
while it doesn't seem to solve the
problem in the way that one might like
to
there's a reason that this problem
continues to uh
to march forward and that's because it
is very difficult to deal with so
planting seeds may be the best option
you have available but
certainly don't feel bad about the fact
that it isn't obvious to you about
what you might do because nobody's
figured out the solution on this one yet
it's raining raining interesting yeah
all right
um i'm going to read the next question
and then i'm going to
the camera's going to go on you and i'm
going to go have toby pull some stuff
inside because it's um
it's raining yeah i didn't see that
coming
all right um this is just just came in i
have not seen this question yet
regarding the finding that people with
high anxiety or increased risk of
suffering severe illness from covert 19.
could it be that our more anxious
ancestors were good at avoiding
transmissible disease due to their
anxiety
at the cost of producing offspring that
never acquired the mechanisms needed to
fight these diseases
um yeah this is a this is a tough one i
think i understand what you're getting
at
uh if i understand it correctly what
you're suggesting
is that anxiety might be a mechanism
of disease resistance that would then
leave a vulnerability at a more
mechanistic level but there's something
oddly circular here which is to say
why would sarsko v2 be dealing
uh would be interfacing differently with
that system in other words either
anxiety is generally protective in which
case you would expect it to be
protective for starzkov2 as well
or it's not generally protective and it
comes with a vulnerability
and then you would see that pattern
rather than
it's good for avoiding diseases except
this one now you mean you could make an
argument that certain diseases yes
certain diseases know and you would have
a
trade-off which might have some
predictable pattern
which would allow us to test the
hypothesis but it's a little a little
hard to see whereas
we know i mean you know we
back to the discussion we were having
earlier about the fact that there's a
an adaptive version of things and then
there's a malignant version of things
yeah anxiety is clearly such a thing
anxiety serves you right your anxieties
will keep you alive
if they're well tuned well i think
that's where this question is emerging
from
right right but but my point would be
the
what we call anxiety is pathological
anxiety and pathological anxiety is very
hard on the body
for various reasons and so it wouldn't
be surprising if it
rendered you vulnerable to disease which
is not the same thing as saying anxiety
does it's like saying pathological
anxiety is one of the comorbidities
right and yet we we allied the
pathological part
that's what that'd be my best guess
allied yes oh that's good i like that
friends so i don't i'm not familiar
enough with the reference to know what
to make of this
friends have compared the
anti-unvaccinated movement
to invasion of the body snatchers so i
just don't it's been forever since i had
any
interface with invasion of the body
snatchers do you think this is an
adverse reaction of the vaccine
reasonably intelligent people losing
their ability to recognize
truth love the fog of war
machine reference and i'm sorry to hear
about moxie i'm a cat lover too
um you know i've joked
i've joked to this effect yes you have
but maybe certain certain people are
experiencing
um like post-vaccine syndrome um
but but i don't think at large
no but that is what is going on that's
what's what is explaining the
um the increasing tribalism
and uh pointing of fingers at some
portion of the population as degenerates
and dirty and deplorable
i don't think that's a post-vaccine
syndrome uh
thing yeah i think it is
something that is being cultivated yeah
and it is resulting in people's
uh worst least humane
impulses governing their style of
of interaction and you know
i forget where it was recently
said there's something about
your oh i know where it was recently
said it was recently said in the patreon
discussion that i had with uh
my supporters this morning um
a psychologist pointed out that there's
this embattled state that causes people
um not to be in their clearest mind
and there's no question about that if
one feels threatened or embattled one is
dealing with a much
more limited set of tools and i just
have the sense that all these smart
people
are um fighting from this limited set of
tools
and what i don't know for sure but i
suspect they're being induced
to use those tools to keep them from
thinking because
thinking would result in you know
lots of questions about the many
elephants in the room yeah
no and i think i mean i think i referred
also to the sort of generalized stress
response a couple of episodes ago
and um you know there's a reason that
acute stress that acute
acute problem acute trauma um creates a
a situation a set of responses um that
do make people want to just be like no
don't ask questions like we need to get
this done we'd like this is this is life
or death here right now
and that itself you know that response
is adaptive
but not when it becomes chronic right
like and that's that's what we're
experiencing now we're like a year and a
half in
and people have sort of adopted as a
chronic position
what what needs to have been an acute
response
yeah and you know it's funny how
frequently people
deploy arguments to me privately
arguments that we have in fact made so
there's no reason to deploy these
arguments because at the very least
you know it's you're not bringing
something new you're making an argument
that we have made right
for example the um the game theoretic
problem that causes
a vaccination campaign to be endangered
by
those who might wish to have the benefit
of the vaccine
without the cost the free rider issue
right
people will bring that and say you know
as if as if this is news as if we
weren't talking about this frankly
before
covet right so
there is a
defaulting to an assumption about what
is being said
what are the blind spots of the person
making the argument and what comes back
is some sort of generic wall of
arguments
deployed in no coherent fashion yeah and
uh i just wish there was some mechanism
to get the people who under ordinary
circumstances understand how to sort
through a puzzle like this one
to get them to stop think about what
they're saying
ask is it possible i am missing a side
of the story and the thing is that
that's really what's stopping it is
there can be nothing on the other side
that would be reasonable therefore i'm
not going to worry about whether i've
missed anything because what would i
have missed the answer is boy you've
missed a lot it's
it's the conclusion driven thinking yep
again yes
i was hoping you were going to say stop
drop and roll
but you didn't no no i mean were you on
fire
i would have you would have recommended
that yes good very
very very i mean it's on a very short
list of useful remedies in that
situation
at least useful words to use on a person
right
yeah you might have gathered supplies
um right and
there is a sink it's hooked up um i you
know
there is a part of me that would have
taken a moment to sort between stop drop
and roll and
duck and cover really which you know
were someone on fire that was a
particular hazard to planet earth
there'd be some
momentary question about which of those
to deploy but and you think that
describes me
no no no in your case it would it's stop
drop and roll that i would be looking
for
and uh yeah i would i would i'd say it
right away as soon as i figured out
that that's what was going on yeah well
i'm relieved i guess
okay what evidence for ivermectin as
prophylaxis is available other than the
argentina study
i was about to get j j a month ago i
came across your podcast and the
toxicity of the spike protein
i followed test larry as well it sounds
reasonable but many mds reject the
observational data what is your take
um so we did there's a section on this
and it's not
exhaustive but we go through four
different types of evidence
in the piece that um that we posted on
my sub stack the um
on driving stars kobe 2 extinct so um
there's the meta-analysis which yes only
has two
papers in it at this point um uh there's
the argentina study
uh there's the evidence out of africa um
in which uh many many countries in
africa
are already using chemoprophylaxis um
for other things for non-covert things
and so two different groups of
researchers thought to compare
uh coveted rates in those countries that
already were giving their people
ivermectin
as opposed to those countries that were
not and indeed they found
um both both studies independently found
that there were much lower rates of
covet in those countries
in which people were already taking
evermectin and then there's
um uh you know looser evidence
um done by this data analyst juan jaime
i think that's
jamie i'm not sure how to pronounce his
last name um
largely out of a number of indian states
and mexico as well and there's also a
mexico study that is not in there that's
that's got some really strong evidence
so
um you know there's there's a lot and
i'm sorry but anyone who says
uh many mds reject you know rejected the
observational data like you can
certainly say like i reject that data
um in part because it's observational
but if you say
i reject observational data then you
don't understand what science is and
you're not doing your patients
any any favors you know you can test a
hypothesis with experiment you can test
it with
observation you can't test all
hypotheses with either experiment or
observation
some can only be tested one way or the
other and indeed
over an animal behavior space where i've
spent the most time
is one of the fields in which you're
most likely to be able to
say okay given that i have this these
hypotheses on the table i could
do this with a carefully designed
observational study or an experiment
which would also have to be carefully
designed but the idea that evidence
shall never come
in the form of an observational study is
frankly anti-scientific and suggests
that the person saying it has not
thought through what evidence
is and it also just violates the
history of science and especially
medical science and all of the
interventions that have been
discovered observationally it's a way to
shut down discussion right
it's a it's a strong man again you can
say
i don't i don't think that observational
data uh
that observational evidence uh is strong
evidence
in part because it is observational um
but if that's the only reason that you
disparage it then that's not an argument
yep
do you believe that garrett vandenbush's
predictions regarding viral immune
escape are coming true
do you have proof have any intuition do
you have any intuition as to how
virulent coven may become
to the vaccinated implications on
society if it's severe okay that's like
four questions right there we can focus
on one or two let's
put it this way it is
not proven there are arguments one could
deploy
to suggest that what vandon bush
predicted is not happening but
vandenbush's predictions appear to be
matching what is happening far better
than any other predictions i've seen
so i think the point is
predictive power is the coin of the
realm when somebody
tells you something that you don't know
and it turns out to be
true you have to give the benefit of the
doubt which doesn't mean we couldn't
discover that there's some other
explanation
for the pattern other than the one
phantom bush has put forward
but i think frankly the prediction
stands up
so far and that that auto
that ought to give us pause about where
we are in this process and what might be
coming next
yep i agree um and i would say just to
the question about
any intuition as to how virulent code
may become to the vaccinated
at least with regard to delta it looks
like it's becoming more transmissible
but less heinous like you know it seems
to do
it seems to send fewer people to the
hospital into their deaths
but it transmits more easily which is
indeed
um absent you know all else being equal
what you tend to expect
of a virus as it evolves with you know
with a host any host in this case humans
yep gender dysphoria is no longer
classified as a mental and behavioral
disorder
according to the who which kind of
disorder is it then
and how is it different from body
integrity identity disorder and other
mental disorders
so i don't know what body integrity
identity disorder is but um
yeah the idea that we're
taking away you know the stigmatizing
terms
yeah uh is again you know indication of
capture
and of confusion and um
you know i mentioned this book uh last
week helen joyce is
trans and um i've i still haven't read
all of it i've been reading other stuff
but i was listening to her being
interviewed by julian vigo on julian's
um
podcast savage minds which is a terrific
conversation
and um you know and she like we
helen joyce um makes this explicit
distinction between
trans people the extremely rare people
who are actually trans
and the trans activists and um
you know the the idea the way that so
many of us so many of us
you know well-intentioned you know
liberals and otherwise
were sort of hijacked early on into
being like oh well yeah of course like
if you if you say so
sure um and it's become
it's become something that's
unfalsifiable about what you're not
allowed to ask questions
and um now that it's you know if it's if
it's not to be considered
something that's in any way unusual to
you know to deny the biological reality
of sex well
you know all bets are off like what what
what hope is there for
for a sensible conversation then right
and at some level
this is just verging into absurdity with
respect to people's sensitivity
right even if the terms aren't precise
they serve
a purpose and it does seem to be a
disorder what are the
you know what are the chances that your
perception of your gender and your
body morphology being out of sync with
each other
is not some sort of a disorder right
that's not a judgment
right that's just saying there's
something about these two things that is
not a match that's not the way nature
typically works
and frankly it's as good a justification
as anything else
for rights and remedies and right
gender gender follows sex gender
inherently will tend to be a mac
a match for sex when it isn't there's
going to be a problem
uh and the idea that that's not a
disorder well then are you saying sex
isn't real like
what actually are you saying and you
know it's just like it's like mountain
bailey's all the way down too
so yeah we've got two things tangled
okay there's more than that but what are
the two they're at least two things
okay one is you and i agree that there
is
some there is evidence of ancient
transness
there is also almost certainly modern
transness that is the result of
some kind of novel influence could be
anything it could be
hormone disruptors it could be
advertisers it could be any at any level
there could be some developmental
interference
that results in mismatches and
in any case well and then and then then
there's
also the very much larger population
than either of those
of people who are declaring themselves
trans who are not
who wouldn't be recognized as such by
right who appears to be
appear to be taking advantage of it or
or fooled themselves
right whether whether or not they are
actively either consciously or
unconsciously just you know fooled
themselves
into into becoming you know prey to an
ideology
yeah um in any case we have to be able
to talk about
things the idea that we're going to
upend all of our language
around sensitivities which is what it
amounts to
right right you know you you see
language doesn't even work this way
right you know i mean as we pointed out
before black people aren't black
white people aren't white right these
terms are not precise descriptions of
anything
but you know if you suddenly can't say
white because
you know because white is pink right
we're not going to have a conversation
in which we can even convey a meaning
like do you really want to destroy our
ability to convey meaning it's really
one of the things that makes humans
special
does the disaster of merrick's disease
in chickens due to leaky vaccines
relate to covered vaccines in any way
would this have been prevented if they
didn't vaccinate the chickens
yes we don't know whether it relates to
our covid situation it's too early to
tell
right i mean we talked about it um
we talked about the paper that did that
research um
it's from like 2015 i think um both
on the podcast and in the paper in our
paper um
with regard to providing some empirical
evidence that this
this is understood to be an outcome at
least sometimes
when you mass vaccinate with a leaky
vaccine um
when a disease is in this case i think
endemic rather than pandemic but
the distinction may be um not important
here
um would this have been prevented if
they didn't vaccinate the chickens and i
think
you know difference between marek's
disease and covid
is that as terrible as cove it is the um
you know the fatality rate the case
fatality rate is not nearly as high like
merrick's disease just like
wipes through populations as i
understand it i think well
with a caveat okay uh the caveat being
these were domestic chickens
yeah um and domestic chickens are
a unique critter among other things
they have had their telomeres elongated
um
by of course they must have but do you
know that yeah i do okay
um but it's it's like successful just by
the same breeding protocol as elongated
the telomeres of the lab mice
right presumably it's the same thing we
don't know for sure
yeah that we don't know um but so
merrick's disease is a neoplastic
virus a rare virus that causes cancers
um
these creatures are likely to be
cancer-prone i don't know i didn't know
it was neoplastic
right so anyway the point is uh with the
caveat the chickens are not
a good model for anything by virtue of
their distortion
yeah through their breeding process who
knows but
the idea that we are dealing with an
issue of
um driving escape mutants with leaky
vaccines
possible ade you know these things are
on the table
and what merrick's disease has to tell
us is uh proceed with caution because
welcome to complex systems
yeah yeah and just i mean just let's be
clear so you
you know in the first hour first hour
and a half you were talking about the
way that joe rogan has been
um strawmanned and said to say things he
didn't say and i think the quote that
you read or
suggested that um he said that
vaccinations
um create mutants right cause mutation
cause mutations did not say which i i
see that
cause mutation could be equilibrium
equalized to create mutants and
the selective pressure which you just
said correctly but
could be misunderstood by those who
weren't paying careful attention or who
wanted to misconstrue
don't get the difference or let's just
like who don't you know it's it's a
little subtle
right that there will you know all these
viruses
are are replicating and they've all got
variation
in them right right and so the mutations
are happening regardless
and if you've got a va if you've got a
selective pressure in the form of
vaccine that's now coming in and going
on some number of them you know those
those things that already exist those
mutants those mutations that already
exist in the population that for
whatever reason
aren't um you know aren't coverable by
the vaccine
will be more likely to thrive it's not
that the vaccine created them they
already existed but they will grow
in abundance relative to the other
strains
if they are not susceptible to the
selective pressure which is the vaccine
right but from the point of view of what
joe rogan
said he said and he was just reading a
paper but the point was
the vaccines select for these things
right
that's neither here they're rare like i
just thought that this was an important
obviously joe rogan didn't say the thing
that they said and you didn't say the
thing that people will misread is you
just having said
i think it's important for us to as many
times as possible
be very clear about what is actually
meant because
you know there's now papers out that
seem to say this with regard to covid in
which some of the authors of those
papers even are like oh no no
you know definitely there won't be any
selective pressure and you hear them
talking you think
you don't you don't actually understand
how evolution works yeah
and um we i i just this this wasn't
about joe rogan it was just like
reminding us i know but i'm i'm involved
in that exact
discussion at this moment and it is
important to be clear
it's the selection that is the
consequence of the vaccine so why don't
you again so i've just said it clearly
why don't you again say it clearly just
let me have it as many times
as possible the hypothesis
is that the vaccines create immunity
that then select
for some variance right so mutation
makes
changes it is not creates
right presumably uh mutation is random
it doesn't have to be but that's the
presumption of
almost every model and selection exerted
by the immune system on a leaky
vaccine a on a breakthrough case that
results from a leaky vaccine
will be for those variants that are most
invisible to the immune system which
will then
likely be invisible to the next
vaccinated person's immune system too
because it's the same immunity that is
induced good
so this one refers to a question from
last week
and i'm not sure i remember the question
from last week well enough to understand
this clarification but we'll try anyway
okay um my placebo question from last
week was
meant more do you remember the placebo
question no okay
uh was meant more to ask if the jab is
safer than we think and
breakthrough case is less likely if
people are erroneously self-reported
as being vast and how might varys data
be affected
um i think i get the question
it's hard for me to imagine how somebody
who isn't vaccinated
but reports that they are ends up in the
vares database if they have
a breakthrough case i don't see it
well i mean i think you know the the
resistance to theirs
is that anyone can enter their
information
yeah and uh you know i've
cited a paper here a few times that says
you know at least
these are the people who are looking at
250 deaths that have been reported in
theirs
to see how it is they were recorded at
least some of them were clearly vaccine
related but they were all reported as
covet deaths right it's that paper
and part of the work that those authors
did um was also carefully
look at um the sources of the of the
vares reports and what they found was
and i'm
somewhat imprecisely remembering the
numbers was something more than 70
percent were 100 confirmable as either
health professionals or pharmaceutical
professionals so um you know
the number of people who could be
self-reporting um
and you know and just trying to mess up
the signal in theirs
um isn't you know isn't the majority and
it's probably a tiny tiny minority
i i'm still just thoroughly confused by
the question because
so okay you've got professionals who
will not be
tricked by somebody's falsely reporting
that they're vaccinated
i don't see why somebody
if somebody's going to report false
stuff into the various system why does
it matter
that any event at all has happened
so the question suggests that people
falsely reporting that they're
vaccinated but correctly reporting that
they've come down with covet or
something
are showing up in the system and i think
the thing is malevolent people who are
trying
to put bad data into the system the
other the opposite pattern
yeah you don't you don't expect any
event at all to be necessary people
putting bad data into a system to mess
up that system
don't have to have had a case of kovid
they don't have to have had an adverse
event so
i don't i don't understand why i mean
there's just
yeah there's a lot of ways it could go
so it's not clear which way the pattern
pattern would run unfortunately if
somehow the question has disappeared so
i can't go back and
look at it
is tribalism a necessary social glue
thus always going to undermine science
and collective sense making
or will signs always undermine tribalism
and its glue benefits
um a little a little bit i mean there's
there's a tension
and you know what we need what we need
is the tension and sort of
going back and forth a little bit maybe
or maybe we don't need that maybe we
mostly need a lot more focus on science
but
tribalism has you know group membership
has benefits
i think this is a culture consciousness
question and the problem is
that um we don't quite have a coherent
culture
we have a start on a coherent culture um
and so in some sense the novelty of the
modern era
and the absence of an ancestral culture
that is coherent because it's many
cultures
effectively condemns us to have to
um accept the bias and the direction of
the conscious mode which in this case
would be a scientific enlightened mode
well and you know and then the problem
over on the science side you said well
the problem over in
culture science is not coherent and so
the culture side isn't
isn't working but the problem over on
the consciousness side
is that uh probably all science always
but especially modern science with its
perverse incentives with regard to
market forces
has become one of preserving the status
quo making it more cultural than
conscious
right instead of science what we have is
science tm now with more science
mm-hmm now with more follow the science
now with more follow-up
with even more follow the science same
great follow the science
now new packaging all new packaging yeah
yeah new color scheme gotta love it
um i don't think we know
these people but i'll read the question
have you heard about the lectica
learning model by dr dawson and dr stein
about how to become good educators like
yourselves in today's world
nope nope interested but yeah
um hi both your pun dynamic got me
thinking
is it fair to say that women generally
more skillfully wield a disapproval and
anger in relationships
i think as with almost everything
that there will be male typical and
female typical ways of doing things
so you know the male typical way of
wielding anger is more likely to be
physical frankly and the female typical
way of wielding anger is more likely to
be social
or linguistic and you know within a
functioning relationship
you hope that there's not very much
anger at all
and certainly no physicality that isn't
wanted by both sides so um
you know i don't know from skillfully
right i think
there are skillful ways of wielding
disapproval that are male typical and
there are skillful ways of wielding
disapproval they're female typical but
given that puns seem more likely to be a
male inflicted form of humor
inflicted not inflected yeah that
the the the females who are in the
receiving end are more likely to wield
the disproval
in perhaps female typical ways
um i'm not quite sure what to say about
this i mean i do
feel like there is a you know this is
it's clearly another
instance of there's an adaptive
form of uh the phenomenon
and then there is the malignant form
are we talking about puns now or
disapproval no the puns
right the ability to cause really the
disagreement is
whether or not it has crossed over
right the punster is is going to be
less likely to see that there's been a
crossover event and the
person on the receiving end is more
likely to see it but probably both of
them are being a little bit too generous
with their own perspectives
right but you have to understand what
the purpose of hunting is
in order to even evaluate whether or not
it's gone
yeah i think you do okay right and the
problem is it's
it's a it's a tricky problem because a
really
properly functioning pun causes a great
deal of suffering but no
actual harm to the victims right whereas
a malignant pun does do a kind of
permanent harm
and you know one wants to tread right up
to that line without crossing it that's
that's the ideal is it
well played
wow you didn't know how diabolical it
was did you
no i didn't now you do i didn't uh what
are your thoughts on the legal battle
between odyssey and the sec
worrying or not um
we don't know a ton about it we know
that it exists yeah
and we know sort of roughly the realm um
that there's an issue especially with
these
smaller cryptocurrencies uh
about whether one is engaged in
something tantamount to
currency manipulation um but
i know nothing about the history of who
owns what and
where it came from uh
yeah i suspect no i'll just
leave it there yeah um
can an animal sleepwalk my cat seems to
display this behavior
thank you um
i see no reason why not they seem i i
guess i see no reason why not
as well i see i definitely don't think
i've ever
observed a cat sleepwalking i'm
sure i would have paid attention right
um i think it should be very rare
by virtue of the fact that creatures
that do this probably don't leave
as many descendants as those that don't
and so in some sense it may be
that um humans you know
well it may be developmental uh entirely
rather than
rather than in the genetic layer and
given that we're talking about
domesticated animals
well i guess the question wasn't
inherently about domesticated animals
but once we're talking about
our pets most of which are um
you know genetic dead ends because we've
had them sterilized
most of us um then assuming it's
developmental
it wouldn't necessarily stop
you know stop happening at the
population level right
i'm just thinking that there would be a
very strong
bias against so basically what you have
is a failure of
sleep paralysis yeah and that
the fail-safes on the sleep paralysis
would be substantial in any creature
that would likely would be liable to end
up
walking into the mouth of a predator or
off a cliff yeah um
well i mean i guess most people with
dogs have noticed the sleep running
right they just tend to do it while
lying on their sides but i also wonder
what would be required to get that dog
to like go 90 degrees and do their sleep
running well
actually well what you need is a
platform with a hinge and
[Laughter]
yeah but i wonder actually if the dog
isn't the exception that proves the rule
in other words you might predict that
domestic dogs would do
far more sleep running and gobbling and
whatever else they do
than the wolves if they got more
opportunity in real life
no that the
long the fact that dogs have this
extremely long
history in captivity would put them more
in the human
situation where you know sleep activity
would be less dangerous because
you know they're hanging out with people
and people
are protective and anyway if you
compared
domestic dogs okay to wolves i would
imagine that wolves would be more like
every other creature and
uh domestic dogs would be more like
people yeah
i like that that's good what are your
thoughts on eating moldy food
after removing the moldy parts i feel
very i feel wary about doing so but so
far i've never had any issues
this is interesting right i mean it
depends on what the food is
for one thing so um you know i've said
for decades
you know cheese and we've said this here
and i think we say in their book you
know maybe we don't say it in the book
no it's there is it yeah um
you know you slice off the moldy parts
and you eat the good stuff underneath
and you're fine
uh and you know bread moldy bread
uh at least some of the mold that grows
on bread turns out to be
uh you know protective it's it's
penicillin and so that you know
this is the reason uh that before we had
an
understanding of antibiotics it was the
poorer people who couldn't afford fresh
bread
and gosh is it going to have been
england i don't i don't know my history
well enough but there's some particular
historical story
of the aristocrats who only ever ate
totally fresh bread
who are more likely to succumb to
whatever it was that people were then
succumbing to that could have been
treated with penicillin but instead of
pill form it came in
the form of the actual um the actual
i guess yeah yeah um
aspergillus penicillium did i make that
up i probably made that up
is that right okay um so you know it
depends but on the other hand you find
mold growing on your meat
do not eat and and you know my sense has
always been i actually haven't pursued
this but like just don't don't touch any
of that even if it's like ground meat
and you can like
no because um the hyphy of the
fungus it seems like i don't know
there's just some the fungus that grows
on meat is
more likely to be toxic well i would
guess
that rule of thumb level how bad it
stinks would be a decent indicator of
how hazard it is
how hazardous it is you've got the rare
cases
of fungi that could leave a
chemical trace sufficient to be
dangerous
but my guess is in general the
um the foodborne stuff is not
liable to be so bad uh you know i
wouldn't necessarily recommend it
but yeah in terms of whether there's any
particular
reason to avoid it i would say avoid the
obviously
fungus infested stuff and yeah i mean
maybe
because as meat begins to go off it
smells regardless
like you know meat with fungus always
has a smell
and so just like you know put it away uh
you know get
get rid of it yeah do not eat i believe
there's
some i have to look into it
there's some exception to this but i
can't get to what it is
i'm not sure what it's some food stuff
anyway i'll see if i can't figure out
what it is
okay uh do you have a thoughts do you
have any thoughts on the cdc study that
natural immunity is less likely to
protect than vaccine
i don't know this study we've uh talked
about and
put on in the show notes and into that
paper
yeah into that paper uh that we posted
um
a couple of studies that that show uh
that natural immunity provides really
excellent protection and one of those
papers specifically compares it to
the protection afforded by the vaccines
and finds that natural immunity is
better
right so i'd like to know i'd like a
reference on what study this is
um but i know that there are um good
studies that suggest
the opposite at least one study that
explicitly suggests the opposite and
another that
specifically suggests very long-lasting
natural immunity
from the disease in the same moment that
we are being told that maybe
six-month boosters are going to be
required at infinitum right and we
haven't seen the pattern
of people who were infected earlier in
the pandemic having no apparent immunity
left so the waning immunity hasn't shown
up
right also in principle there's the
simple fact that the virus itself
carries many antigens and the vaccine
specifically only one
right so uh there's a question about
what
the basis the breadth of the immunity
certainly should be greater from for the
the pathogen itself
there's the remote possibility that you
could engineer a vaccine
that would be so effective that it would
create longer lasting immunity but as
you point out the
wreck of the booster recommendations uh
don't suggest that this is what's going
on so
anyway i guess i would say i remain to
be convinced by any such
paper and i'd be interested to look into
the method section in particular and see
if there's not something lurking there
yep
totally it takes time to lose weight and
many are hundreds of pounds overweight
it's not reasonable that they can lose
enough to be safe from coven
well yes there are people who are
morbidly obese and beyond morbidly obese
that's not most people who are
overweight and anything that you can do
to start taking control of your own
health
is helpful yep totally and it because
because
safe from covet no no one is safe from
coven yep you know even
even young healthy children have have
died and that's extraordinarily rare so
no one is safe regardless of
of how many boxes you tick in terms of
being apparently
relatively more safe than you could be
but
presumably and i haven't seen data to
this effect but presumably being 100
pounds overweight
is safer that from covert than being 200
pounds overweight
right so it's not it's not binary
love your work dark horse numbers 1
through 91 highlight of my week
from somerset uk awesome thanks
i have a thought about paddle boarding
and using sunglasses and sunscreen
is that much exposure to the sun a bug
of modernity that makes these
necessary i would say
sunglasses and sunscreen are two
different things um
and it's possible that something will
emerge
that suggests that actually protecting
our eyes with sunglasses
um is also causing some kind of problems
and i remember
my field assistant in madagascar jessica
um
who was british who'd grown up um she's
a
daughter of a diplomat and had grown up
in countries in africa and also
madagascar
but she's british by birth and um she
used to marvel that i wear sunglasses
when we'd emerge from the field in the
forest
um on to the onto the beach of the
little island that we were working on
off of the coast of madagascar she's
like you americans in your sunglasses
i'm like you know we're practically on
the equator here and i've got the sun
beaming down from the sky and glinting
off the water why wouldn't i wear
sunglasses
and it was really just a cultural
difference it's like we brits don't wear
sunglasses like i said only because it's
cloudy where you're from and you should
be wearing sunglasses now right yeah
they keep a stiff upper island
that's that's right um so i have never
um avoided sunglasses um when it felt
like
you know i was squinting otherwise to
protect my eyes and you know i think
that's what we do we behaviorally
protect our eyes
whereas sunscreen um you know we can
behaviorally protect our skin
too you know if we can if if the sun is
so bright you don't have sunglasses and
you're squinting in order not to
uh not to feel that your eyes are
hurting
that is a behavioral modification and if
you are out in the sun
and it's not just that you feel hot but
your skin begins to feel hot
you need to behaviorally modify if you
possibly can
and and get out of the sun and i you
know so i don't i don't wear sunscreen i
do very very very occasionally but i
haven't so far this year
applied any sunscreen i tend to go
paddle boarding in the early morning
so not between the hours of 10 and 2
largely
i was i did get a late start one morning
this week and
was out came off the water close to noon
and it was hot and not only was it hot
but it really had felt like there was no
escape
and so i tend to i'm you know i'm paddle
boarding mostly on the willamette and
there are some islands that i like to go
to and
you know you get an island and you can
go accept it you know the very peak
of the day and you can get into some
shade and that's what i tend to do and
this wasn't possible and i it did feel
like
i was pushing a little bit much it was a
little bit too much exposure with no
possible
reprieve you know i don't know what
you're going to think about this you
probably weren't dressed for it but
you could also get in the water and use
the shadow of your paddle board
as a reprieve yeah true yeah i wasn't um
i wasn't wearing a swimsuit i i probably
should be at this point it's just the
well this is the weather for it but
yeah i totally would if i was doing it
because then you could go for a swim and
get back on your board
yeah but anyway i wanted to point out
something about the sunglasses issue
yeah which is that in some sense the
sunglasses
may be a negative they may well be a
negative
in some circumstances but there's also
stuff that we do
that requires them there's a road here
that is
absolutely undrivable for a month or so
as the sun
sets because the sun it's a hill you're
looking
right into the sun you just cannot see
what is ahead of you unless you
are wearing them so there's that there's
the
case of inuit using sunglasses made i
think they're made of bone
with the slats little louvers in them oh
um
yeah it's a it's a cool looking device
yeah but anyway it suggests there's kind
of an ancient history of tinkering in an
environment that's unusually bright
that's cool um
there's also the fact many of us have
experienced uh
careless skiing and sunburning our
retinas
um that sounds fun it's not fun
yeah um but what do you uh what do you
do
about that uh suffer a lot
and wait for it to heal i can't closing
your eyes make it worse or better
uh you see stuff when you do that when
you close your eyes it's a long time
it's been decades since i had any
and i didn't have a very serious case
but um yeah so anyway
point is unusual environments
require some intervention unusual
technologies like driving require some
intervention
it may be that we overuse sunglasses it
may be
especially since eyes don't typically
get cancer they do tend to wear out
they're one of those tissues that's all
the way over on that side of the
spectrum it may be that we are
protecting them from damage that we are
effectively slowing their aging by
blocking a certain amount of the
photons coming in it's effectively a
neutral density filter
um which is a you know a fine technology
it just
blocks at random some fraction of the
photons yeah
but anyway there's a question to be
answered is there a harm to sunglasses i
don't know
but it's possible
do you still read the new york times for
the bizarre entertainment
i admit that every once in a while i
watch alex jones scream about black
helicopters
i think it's alex jones it just says
jones um the bizarre entertainment
yeah you know i just haven't been able
to convince myself to
lose a super lose the subscription lose
the subscription
yet right and i do and because i
pay to have it arrive once a week i do
try to
look at it and then you know when i do
this happens
well i mean there's also something to be
said for just knowing
what some large demographic is thinking
absolutely it is a pretty good window
into a certain style of thought
true true true um let's see what are we
at time why
you are at 50 all right so we're gonna
we're gonna try to keep this to an hour
uh today any more information about the
lipid nanoparticles collecting in the
body
i've seen nothing i have seen nothing um
you know some of these questions we just
you know why did robert malone take the
modernity vaccine after he had already
had copen
oh i think boy i hope i'm not telling
tales out of school but i
think the answer is that he had some
long covets
syndrome and that there was an
indication
that vaccination was somewhat helpful i
think that's right if i've got it wrong
it's just because i've misremembered
something but i think that was
that was it okay do you anticipate the
development of newer and improved
vaccines
however greater early attempts may have
been i would expect as with many
inventions and technologies that it can
be improved with additional attempts and
time i certainly hope so
and i have begun to look just a little
bit into novofax and you know who knows
what we can actually see and what we're
being told but i am hopeful
um i'm i'm worried i've heard murmurs
about novo vx
potentially not being properly
formulated but the idea
could be potentially better and frankly
there could be something a lot better
and
it would be great if we had a non-leaky
vaccine built on a traditional platform
i worry
what yes what
um what is the alternative to
authorization
it is called approval i am concerned
about what approval
of current vaccines will do to that
process maybe nothing but
i would like somebody to tell me what
the implications are
if full approval occurs yeah
um
simplistic question to these i'm just
seeing for the first time
uh does x y imply a mutation given the
regularity of x
x would that make the female sex more
ancient
um so chromosomal sex determination
the the what mammals have and what also
birds have it's a separate evolution of
chromosomal sex determination but also
some groups of reptiles have but again
separate evolutions of chromosomal sex
determination
in mammals except for the monotremes the
duckbill platypus and echidnas
uh we have the well known to us system
of females being xx and males being xy
chromosomal sex determination is far
more new
than sex itself and so the
way that we that that zygotes end up
being um you know being told being
informed
um that they are either male or female
is by in the case of humans
you know the sex chromosomes the
chromosomes of that 23rd
um position
uh and it's you know some different
different position in all the other
mammals
um but that comes long after there's
already been
sex in existence so um you know xxxy
is newer than sex that said
you know what sex would we think of all
the organisms being
in a non-sexually reproducing species we
think of them being female
because what what females bring
in their gametes in our gametes is
cytoplasm
is the you know what do you need in
order to achieve sexual reproduction you
need the dna
from yeah the dna from two different
individuals to come together and this is
true of all plants all animals
um the dna of two different individuals
to come together um
and and join but there's actually two
other things that you need that are
implied by that story
right you need um the other cellular
machinery of the cell you need the
cytoplasm you need things like
mitochondria and ribosomes
and someone's got to bring that and if
both players bring that they're going to
argue over who's
they get to use and so
we call the one who brings that the
female and we call that gamete the egg
the egg is the cytoplasm rich gamete
then the other problem you need to solve
is how do you find each other
and so you've got this really large
bicellular standard cell
that is the egg that's filled with
cytoplasm and now
if it was going to move around it'd be
pretty slow because it's it's laden with
all this stuff
and so the other gamete the other type
of gamete which we call in plants pollen
or we call an animal sperm
is stripped down it has basically no
cytoplasm it's basically half a
complement of dna in a motor
and it's the one that zips around
looking for
eggs so the egg solves the problem of
what else do you need besides dna in
order to make a functional being
and the sperm solves the problem of how
do you find
the thing that you're going to combine
with in order to make a functional being
and all of that well predates um
chromosomal sex determination also
is there any evidence that the x and the
y
are homologues i rather suspect that
they're not
i guess that's assumed in the in the
question isn't it
um does x y imply a mutation give number
um i mean like
to the question wrestling i mean i guess
you know like all the other all the
autosomes are x's
effectively i mean they look like x's
right so i guess
i guess i have assumed yes that y is a
is a
sort of a depopperet x and it certainly
is smaller than
but i don't know and i don't know if
science knows i don't know if we know
we should look into it um
yeah because i think if it's not
then um
yeah then the answer to the question is
simply no um
and if it is then you can't call it a
mutation but you could say
right it is a devolved devolved x
yep why does brett constantly repeat
that libertarian or volunteerists are
naive
i don't know what a volunteerist is i've
not heard that yeah but
go go with libertarian um well let's put
it this way there are
people who have libertarian sympathies i
think i probably have
substantial libertarian sympathies but
who are not libertarians ideologically
because of the many failures of game
theory
that are effectively guaranteed by
libertarianism and libertarians will
frequently swear that this is not the
case that they've solved the tragedy of
the commons somehow
and then nothing useful follows
and you know i think the most the best
defense you could make is that you can't
solve the problem so you're better off
just paying the price
because the solutions are worse than the
disease
but that isn't right the eleanor ostrom
work is an elegant demonstration that
these problems are solvable that they
have been solved
uh under ancient circumstances and that
we need modern analogs for those ancient
solutions
uh period the end or we're gonna die of
tragedy the commons
good um let's see i'm just trying to
find we got
here we go if it's true that the biggest
increases in the recent
in the last seven days from rhony deaths
by state
i'm gonna try reading this in my
language because it's a little bit a lot
of words here
if it is true that the biggest increase
is in the last seven days
um of corona
virus deaths by state are in the least
vaccinated states
and vice versa meaning
well vice versa could mean a couple of
things here but imagine that it means
the lowest increases in deaths
are in the most vaccinated states
isn't that a case that the facts that
the vaccine should be supported
uh that nothing is so simple yeah um so
you know of course there's an if it's
true thing at the beginning of this
which the question
um
you know posits as well and there are
early in the pandemic we were hearing
from a lot of people
about um why
are we having conflated died from
rather than died of copen no died from
and died with
yes died from and of being the same so
died from versus died with
and i paid scanned attention to this at
the time
um i think especially what we have now
seen with regard to
monkeying with the baseline with regard
to
for instance people post-vaccination
who are being claimed to have died of
covid
even if they tested negative for kovid
has raised for me the specter of this
rather significantly
that i do not
i would like to see clean data
with regard to covet deaths uh
that wasn't created in service of some
conclusion that already existed before
the data existed
um so that um that is the sort of if
it's true like we don't even know if
it's true but then
then so that's the analysis is also
uh as is so much of the current analysis
overly focused on individual well-being
and instantaneous measures as the
ultimate arbiter
and so what's missing from this is we
don't know what the long-term
impacts are for uh vaccinated people
we don't know how many have been injured
along the way
and how severely but maybe more to the
point
we don't ade is not off the table and
vaccine escape mutants appear to be very
much
on the table and so all of these things
suggest
some net analysis that it does not
appear anybody is doing
everybody is looking for a simple rubric
and it's not a simple problem it's a
complex systems problem
and it really needs uh wise
well-informed people looking at high
quality
evidence without a conflict of interest
and we're like
nowhere near that list of things not
even close
yeah okay uh three more questions and
then we'll stop unless zack are we at an
hour all right
so we'll do three more questions um
one of which um is just hello bretton
heather i would like to call in
um which sort of just amuses me we don't
do call-ins
but uh it could be fun it's an ultimate
reference call it in
bring it in bring it i don't know
all right it's late that's clear that is
clear that's clear
we're gonna have dinner later right
thinking yeah i mean it's good i hope
all of you do as well although for some
of you it's
well past dinner time i imagine it's for
some it's nowhere near dinnertime
i mean hawaii man this is true
the three people in hawaii who watch
um yeah it's the time in the podcast
where fairfax
stretches and shows the back of his head
okay
uh penultimate question india's spike
has disappeared it's a mostly
unvaccinated country
could this be herd immunity um
you know what's going on in india is is
unclear
um but certainly the
one interpretation uh from
some data analysts that we have been
paying attention to and that we have
also put into
our paper describing some of the
evidence and support of ivermectinous
prophylaxis
is that there are many states in india
and even those
that have not been using prophylaxis are
beginning to you know try to
try to pressure the governments to allow
them to um that have been
basically giving giving prophylactic
packets
um to to their people uh
and i hope that's right
well i i certainly hope it's right it
probably isn't right across all of india
there's obviously an interaction between
parts of india that do and parts of
india that don't
and there's this maddening pattern that
we've seen globe wide
where as
the curve goes up
we enact measures as the curve goes down
we lift the measures
and the fact is as the curve goes down
what you want to do is
everything you can to make sure it
continues to go down because eventually
it hits zero
yeah right and so we we're just so
stupid about this game and we're like an
extended latka volterra model
with the virus it's like it's the overs
like we're we're acting like we're in
some
simple predator prey dynamic and uh
well yeah i mean it you know the
predator prayer dynamic is nice because
it keeps
the predator and prey alive indefinitely
and we're in a different dynamic where
we would really like this thing to go
extinct
and we keep opening but yeah it just
seems like
the policies almost seem designed to
keep the virus alive
yes which obviously there's no design
and predator parade dynamics like that
but um that's what the
that's what the slightly offset sign
curves look like
final question can adults learn new
skills just as well as kids
for instance music is an example
no but we can do okay
but for many many skills we lose some of
our plasticity
um and there are for different skills
some particular periods some some key
periods during which
if you are exposed you're likely then
you know if
if you become bilingual young you're
more it'll be more
it'll be more easy it'll be easier to
pick up third fourth fifth languages
later on even
as an adult because you've effectively
primed yourself to have the plasticity
early on and i think the same will be
true for musical instruments
um with regard to language there may be
a trade-off
you know there may be a trade-off to
having lots of flexibility
and you know speaking many many
languages which isn't something that you
know really anyone is saying but
um but yeah getting at least some
flexibility on board
for some of these types of skills the
younger you are is likely to make it
easier later
but that doesn't mean that it's ever too
late
yeah i would love to see this parsed
yeah differently and i'm sure there is
evidence and i just don't know it but i
wonder if language and music aren't
exceptional
and for the very same reason and
other skills aren't so much like this
but there might be
confounding patterns like you know is it
easier to learn to skateboard
as a kid maybe not
but falling off the board is a lot
better and so
so that so the the risk of the the
injury
upon failure is so much lower so it's
better to learn it when you can afford
the failures because you're going to be
failing while you learn
similarly things that require really
either gross or fine motors well
especially
fine motor skills um you are you're not
going to be as good a woodworker at sex
no matter right you're just you're right
your judgment sucks
well your judgment sucks but also so
does your fine motor skills right you
just don't have it on board yet
so there's not going to be certainly not
a single universal answer
but you know just thinking about
you know there are you know
wordsmiths often persist being
wordsmithy uh into into old age
whereas other other kinds of thinking
does seem to fall off and obviously we
know
that atlantic athletic skill does um to
some degree certainly
things like burst speed and raw strength
yeah right i certainly know in myself
that there were puzzles that i would
have found easy to solve like
engineering puzzles that i would have
found easy to solve
at 15 that would be much harder
now on the other hand the
[Music]
the wisdom side of it about what
solutions tend to look like and how one
finds them
is enhanced so there's sort of a raw
computing versus intuition
trade-off but i don't think it's simple
yeah no of of course it's not and i
think you know this is one of the
reasons that having age mixed teams
regardless of whether you're talking
about kids or adults or both um
it can be so so much you know it's going
to be messier
it's going to be less predictable it's
probably not going to go totally
smoothly and as you expected and be the
shortest time to
completion but it's likely to generate
new kinds of wisdom in a way that having
you know perfectly matched you know with
it with the skills on board that you
wanted
in the room um that's just gonna that's
gonna produce
answers that are more like the answers
that have come before and i'm thinking
also of
of ultimate of ultimate frisbee right uh
that at the point that we were playing
we were um we were mostly in our late
20s
mid late 20s and early 30s and so we
were not the youngest players on the
field but we were also nowhere near the
oldest players on the field
and um you know there were some players
in their 40s and 50s
who were extraordinary and you know they
weren't going to tend to be the one who
were like i'm going long throw deep
because there was always some young buck
on the field who was going to be able to
beat them and get to the frisbee first
right
but they were strategic and they were
able to place themselves
where no one else had placed themselves
and thus received the frisbee and throw
it and
um and you know it really is such a
remarkable game in part because
not just does co-ed work um but age
uh age diversity works as well yeah i
agree there's something
i think at some level we artificially
for the same dumb reason that our
classrooms look like a bunch of chairs
facing
the cave wall um that'd be more
interesting we have
aid stratified education
right because it's efficient in some way
but it's probably
really dumb oh 100 is no this i mean i
think
it 100 is and almost all i think
of the alternative educational models
even in the weird world
recognize that that's like one of the
first things to go you know the one room
school house which you know my father
was raised and
was raised he was raised in a farmhouse
with his family but
the one room schoolhouse run by nuns
catholic nuns
in iowa was you know all the grades
together
right right and um that's that's a
classic from ev
you know every every moment until now
and
um i mean i guess well waldorf now does
um age restricted but you know
montessori uh the school that
zach went to for one year before it um
before it disbanded you know the the
the schools that are really trying to
provide agency to the children and allow
them to learn
not only how to learn but also how to
teach which is the most effective way to
learn
exactly has them with people who have
skills that they can't yet attain don't
yet have and can't entertain because
they're so much older than them and also
people with skills
that are so much younger than them that
they don't have that much to teach them
and also
everything in between yeah so that all
of those all of those interfaces are
possible
yep so in two weeks we'll be talking
about school
right so next week the chapter we'll be
talking about its childhood
and the week after that is school so
we'll come we'll come back to that i
feel just slightly too cool for school
i was going to say you always have but
that really wasn't your situation no
that was never that's that was that's
not true
so i didn't say it yes
all right i think we've come to the end
uh so uh
as as always please consider um
sharing this video liking it subscribing
to the channels on both youtube and
odyssey
going to our patreons um
going to my sub stack natural selections
consider some stuff at
store.darkhorsepodcast.org
and if you've been watching on youtube
try it out on odyssey
uh we'd love we'd love to send as many
of our viewers to odyssey as possible
and be good to the ones you love
and eat good food and get outside be
well everyone
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you